what is your favorite lip sync in drag
race hurstery i would have to say hands
down silky nutmeg ganache as barbie girl
come on
my favorite lipstick in drag race
hershey would have to be silky
lipsticking against herself i'm still a
bass bite
[Music]
is because that's my favorite song dua
lipa is physical by lagaya stranger and
trinity
[Music]
[Applause]
both of them they kill him but lagancha
baby that lip scene is at fake like
since the beginning when she drops in
the in the split baby no she killed she
slayed that lip thing and obviously
physique is one of my favorite songs so
i love that
yeah for me it's still to this day uh
sasha velour and shae like i'm sorry the
moment she takes the wig and they just
start falling out of life
[Music]
[Applause]
everything sasha was doing all the
pieces fell into place and it was just
like
perfection so good my favorite lip sync
is definitely the natalie cole lip sync
with theater ritz the emotion that was
coming out of that and the feeling
[Music]
[Music]
the princess this will be that was the
first lip-sync that i ever saw and like
that was probably the reason why i
started watching the show like i saw
that before i saw any of drag race i'm
like i want to know what that's about
it's just
i still remember the choreo and she's
like
[Music]
yeah oh mine's definitely a brooklyn and
uh evie oddly's
[Music]
my absolute favorite a lot of people are
probably going to disagree with me
but it was a five-way lip sync in season
11.
[Applause]
it was like super smash brothers like
all over
what is your favorite lip sync in drag
race her street oh june you look like
you got one shut up and drive
[Music]
sync assassin when you think of lipstick
assassins you think of her tatiana held
her own yeah she did it was it was
fierce it was nice that was one of those
lip things that for me i was like oh yes
that's that was one of those double
chantes that like really deserved it
like yeah i would have gone any other
way i would have been boxing with the tv
um
and i don't box
but it was that was for sure one of my
favorites but also
from season 14 is really good too
honey there are definitely some lip
syncs to watch i'll just tell y'all
[Music]
you